Speaker 1: , you absolutely have to see this
interview from last night with California
potential California gubernatorial candidate
Caitlyn Jenner, of course, of the Kardashians
fame, former Olympian as Bruce Jenner earlier
in life.
Now, Caitlyn Jenner worth one hundred million
dollars personally by most reports, and that
becomes very relevant during the interview.
The current California governor is Democrat
Gavin Newsom.
There's an effort to recall Gavin Newsom.
In order to do this, Californians need to
collect just shy of one point five million
signatures to have a recall.
It appears they've done it.
They've collected one point six million.
But those signatures now have to be validated.
Signers also have 30 days to say, actually,
I signed it, but I don't want to be on the
list anymore.
So at some point, relatively soon, we will
see.
Will the recall be happening now if indeed
it happens?
Caitlyn Jenner has announced that she is running.
Caitlyn Jenner is notable because she is a
trans woman and a Republican, although how
much she knows about politics is in question.
And you will notice that in this interview,
of course, the Republican Party hasn't been
very good to the trans community.
Many have been outright hostile to the trans
community in many ways, including on the bathroom
issue for years now.
So Jenner was interviewed last night by Sean
Hannity and the combination of completely
unrelatable comments about private jets with
Sean Hannity and Hannity just looking so uncomfortable
with the interview makes this one of the most
compelling political interviews in a long
time.
I was watching these clips over and over again
last night, like the Zapruder film preparing
for today.
So let's jump right in.
In this first clip, Caitlyn Jenner tells us,
listen, we've got to solve these problems
in California because you know what?
My neighbor at my hangar where I keep my private
plane, he's thinking of leaving and I'm thinking
of leaving if we don't improve things.
Think of the private plane owners.
This you have to see California.
Speaker 2: My friends are leaving California,
actually work my hair.
The guy across from another friend who was
packing up his hangars.
Where are you going?
And he says, I'm moving to Sedona, Arizona.
I can't take it anymore.
I can't walk down the streets to see the homeless.
I don't want to leave, OK?
Either I stay and fight or I get out of here.
Speaker 1: Why is no one talking about the
marginalized, oppressed private plane owners
thinking of leaving?
This is how bad it is in California, guys.
The private plane owners, they are having
to see homeless people on the way to their
hangar, and that is just terrible.
The private plane owners are this close to
packing up their private jets and flying somewhere
else.
And Caitlyn Jenner is going to keep them in
California if elected governor.
OK, so off to a blazing fast start, as you
can see.
And this is nothing.
It gets even worse.
Now, of course, Caitlyn Jenner was asked by
Hannity about transgender girls in sports.
Republicans know almost nothing about the
trans community.
But the two things they know about and care
about are trans bathroom laws and trans girls
in sports.
Those are the two trans issues for Republicans.
Caitlyn Jenner's answer is a complete mystery
to me.
I've watched this three times.
I'm going to watch it now, a fourth time with
you.
I can't make heads or tails out of this answer.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: I stick with my statements that
I made.
I think we have to make sure that the integrity
of girl sports is there.
I think that's extremely important.
But it's.
There's more to it than just what I said,
because I just said biological boys and sports,
there's more to it than that.
And I think in the future I will explain more
of that.
But for me as a.
A transwoman.
I think role models are extremely important
for young people, trans issues, people struggle
with big time, our suicide rate is nine times
higher than the general public.
And for me to be a role model, for them to
be out there.
I am running.
For governor of the state of California, who
would have ever thunk that we've never even
had a woman?
Governor, but some are mad at you.
That's that, I don't know.
I move on, I want to be a role model and I
think and to be a leader and I think the most
important thing as a leader that you can do
is your compassion, your honesty.
And I think that sometimes is very lacking
in politics.
So I want to be an example to all people,
not just trans people.
This is what you on the support side of it,
though, I don't know why how you came down
on the sports side of the issue.
I don't know why.
To be honest, I don't know why they keep asking
me that.
What do you think, Sean?
I don't know.
Why do they keep asking me that question?
Great question.
It is a good question.
Speaker 1: So what on earth is her position
on the issue of trans girls in sports?
Imagine being a Republican and thinking this
is great, a trans candidate.
Finally, we are going to get clarity.
What is Caitlyn Jenner's position on trans
girls in sports?
What would Caitlyn Jenner do as governor about
trans girls in sports?
And then you hear that and you come out even
more confused.
And then this is just straight out of a comedy
show.
Sean Hannity asks Caitlyn Jenner's position
on forest fires.
And this is I mean, you know, what on earth
would Caitlyn Jenner know about that issue?
But it's a big issue in California.
If you're going to run for governor of California,
you need an answer to this, because forest
fires really are an issue.
And her answer is almost verbatim a Trump
answer about, oh, you've got to do forest
management and would you
Speaker 2: allow controlled burns?
Isn't there a science behind forestry?
Is that science being ignored in this state?
Yes, because when I watch it advantage heart,
I lived in Santa Barbara.
I watched Hope Ranch.
I hope Ranch burned down after I just left
the state.
Yes, yes.
Forest management is extremely important now,
just like at my house.
And it's not even forest management at my
house.
The reason my house made it, because they
say you have to keep any brush.
Fifty or seventy five feet.
I think I had seventy five feet clearance
when the fires came.
They just went around my house so fast it
was because it's moving very fast.
So it's almost the same thing for forest management.
Just a little bit of preparation.
Speaker 1: So there it is.
I mean, guys, just, just do the forest management
and everything will be fine.
Why this is so why do we keep talking about
this?
Just manage the forest and that's it.
And if you thought that was Trumpy.
And in this next clip, Caitlyn Jenner takes
credit for Governor Gavin Newsom loosening
covid restrictions, which is completely out
of the Trump playbook.
Take credit for things that have nothing to
do with you.
And the really funny thing is, Jenner says,
you know, if I were governor, I'd open the
state tomorrow.
If the recall happens, it's months away.
California is opening in five weeks.
So the the Caitlyn Jenner would open the state
tomorrow, except the recall is months away
and California will be open by then.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: Would you open the state of California
completely tomorrow?
Absolutely.
Open it right up.
Actually, you know what?
It's just so close in and out of relief.
It's even on a small scale kind of working
already.
Oh, about three weeks ago, it was rumor and
rightfully so.
It was rumored that I was looking to run for
governor the next day.
Gavin Newsom has a press conference, says
the state is opening up July 15th.
I'm laying there in bed and watching this,
and I'm saying, yes, it's already working.
Speaker 1: So there it is.
Caitlyn Jenner may be responsible for covid
restrictions loosening in July.
All bizarre.
And then Hannity asks Jenner for an assessment
of Trump, Biden and Harris.
When this happened, I you know, I got the
popcorn and got ready.
And her explanation about why Trump good,
Biden bad.
It's the exact meaningless, vapid drivel we
hear from Trump.
Let's take a look at this.
Speaker 2: We've had four years of Donald
Trump.
We have Joe Biden and Kamala Harris.
Give me your assessment of those three people.
What I liked about Donald Trump as he was
a disrupter, you know, he came in and shook
the system out, OK, a lot of people didn't
like that in Washington, D.C., but he came
in and shook the system up.
I think he did some things that I agreed with,
some things I didn't agree with.
I you're critical on transgender issues, on
trans issues, LGBT issues.
I was more hopeful at the beginning.
And but there were some good things he did.
On the other hand, Biden I don't think I've
agreed with anything.
I don't think since he's been in there, he
has done anything for the American worker,
maybe other ones.
So it is a.
It is a 180 degree turn in our country going
the other direction, and it scares me.
Speaker 1: It's almost verbatim what we've
heard from for a long time.
Trump was different.
He shook things up.
He wasn't a politician.
It was a new direction.
It's just meaningless, vapid drivel once again.
And then maybe my favorite clip of the entire
interview.
This is the wrap up Hannity.
Thanks Caitlyn Jenner for doing the interview.
And Jenner brings up the private plane again
and says, let's go for a flight.
And Hannity just looks visibly uncomfortable.
Speaker 2: Caitlyn Jenner, thank you for being
with us.
It was my pleasure.
Always a pleasure to talk to you.
Good to talk to you.
Good to see you.
Now we're going to go find my plane around
the corner.
I'm going to take you for a flight.
I'm going right wheels up any minute, OK?
All right.
Thank you for your time.
We do wish you nothing but the best.
We're going to follow this race closely.
Speaker 1: So there it is.
Just a strange interview.
Trump being in many ways completely lacking
in substance, completely absent was any serious
policy discussion.
And I watched this entire thing.
I don't know why Caitlyn Jenner is running
for governor.
It's not clear to me what Caitlyn Jenner brings
to the table as a gubernatorial candidate.
But seeing Republicans on the one hand, they
want to remove Gavin Newsom.
But at the same time, many of them dislike
trans people as much as they dislike Gavin
Newsom.
And now they've got a transgender Republican
candidate, I guess running if if the recall
ends up happening, they're in a tizzy.
They don't know.
Up is down.
Down is up.
It's bizarro world for them.
So we're going to follow the California situation.
Very interesting to see.
And one of the most unusual interviews I've
ever seen will have clips of it on our Instagram
page as well.
Follow us there at David Pakman show